c'est le drame des singes
astronautes capables et Baker la plus petite
fille, ils sont tous les deux des femelles est Baker, elle est
un singe écureuil d'un étang et est maintenant
au sommet de la capsule spatiale dans laquelle elle a atteint
des sommets historiques Le compagnon de Baker
capable d'un singe rhésus de 7 livres  est à califourchon sur
sa chambre convenablement habillée pour l'espace
et tirée pour la recherche les deux ont été placés
dans le cône de nez d'un missile Jupiter à
Cap Canaveral le décollage est arrivé à trois
heures et demie du matin 10 000 milles à l'heure d'
altitude 300 milles puis après 15 minutes
de vol le nez  le cône a parachuté
dans les Caraïbes près de l'île d'
Antigua les signaux radio du cône du nez
indiquent que les singes sont bien vivants
une minute avant qu'ils n'atterrissent dans l'
eau pas le suspense est là au
moment crucial de la récupération de la mer
pour Abel  et Baker sont les premières
créatures vivantes à être montées dans l'espace et à
revenir vivantes
ou bien sûr, les singes sont
vivants et parfaits sans blessures, les
sauveteurs sont maintenant heureux  ly annoncé au
monde qui attend
mon vicieux Baker enregistre timidement
nonchalant comme s'il osait les simples
humains pour lui donner un tourbillon Abel a ses
propres idées à ce sujet mais plus tard lors de la
première conférence de presse jamais tenue pour deux
singes même ils doivent être impressionnés par le
les progrès scientifiques annoncés pour l'
ère spatiale vers une éventuelle aventure sûre
des êtres humains dans l'espace les premières
découvertes révèlent que le singe n'a montré
qu'une légère variation par rapport à la normale dans le
rythme cardiaque et la respiration et donc l'
armée la marine et l'administration
nationale de l'aéronautique et de l'espace
vous disent Abel  et
Baker bravo les filles